مطار الخرطوم اكبر مطار في السودان يعتبر
المقر الرئيسي ومركز عمليات الخطوط الجويه
السودانيه شهد اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع ما تسبب بتعليق الرحلات
الداخليه والخارجيه في المطار وسط تضارب
في المعلومات عن الجهه التي تسيطر فعليا
على المطار مطار مروي يغطي العمليات
الجويه في شمال السودان ويعتبر من احدث
مطارات البلاد وكانوا نشر قوات الدعم
السريع عشرات الاليات العسكريه في محيطه
بمثابه الشراره الاولى لتفجر الخلافي مع
الجيش وقد اعلن كلا الطرفين عن سيطرتهما
على المطار والقاعده الجويه بعد اشتباكات
عنيفه وسط تاكيد بان المعارك لا تزال
مستمره مطار الابيض المطار الرئيسي في
ولايه شمال كردفان اسفرت الاشتباكات هناك
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش عن مقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص وجرح اخرين في حين اكدت قوات
الدعم السريع سيطرتها على المطار القصر
الجمهوري يقع في اقصى الجزء الشمالي
لمدينه الخرطوم وهو المقر الرسمي لرئاسه
الجمهوريه ويضم مكاتب اعضاء مجلس السياده
شهد محيط القصر اشتباكات عنيفه بين
الطرفين بمختلف انواع الاسلحه اذ سارع
الجيش الى تطويق القصر بالياته الثقيله
رغم اعلان الدعم
في الساعات الاولى من تفجر الاوضاع
تلفزيون السودان يقع في مدينه ام درمان
شهد بث التلفزيون الرسميين قطاعا قصيرا
بعد سماع اصوات اطلاق نار داخل المبنى كما
تعرضت غرفه التحكم الرئيسيه للقصف في حين
اكد المتحدث باسم الجيش ان قوات الدعم
السريع موجوده بكثافه في محيط التلفزيون
الرسمي
مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه يقع وسط العاصمه الخرطوم لا
يزال يشهد محيط المقر اشتباكات متقطعه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وسط تاكيد من
قياده الجيش ان المقر وباقي المرافق
العسكريه الاستراتيجيه في الخرطوم لا تزال
تحت سيطرته الكامله